πληρώνων οι ασθενής και οποία κατα κάποιον τρόπων είναι ανεξελεκτη στην κύπρν δεν υπάρχει αυτό
είναι συγκεκριμένης υ περιπτώσειες που πρέπει και πότε και με ιο ποσών συμπληρώνει ο ασθενς
αυτό απο οικονομικής άποψης για των ασθενή είναι το πρώτατο πρόν πλεον έκτημα το δεύτερον
είναι ότι στην κύ προ με αυτό τω τρόποντο ότι δε έχει συμπληρομή υπάρχει ελευθερι
είναι πραγματικότητα ι ελεύθερη επιλογή η είναι πολύ πιο ελεύθερη η επιλογή των ασθενών στο
γιατρών και στο νοσηλευτιερα πάλιστα δι εαν εμπαιναι μια συμπληρωμή παραδηγμερος χαριπιο ακριβή στο άλφα
ι στο βίτα νοσηλευτύριο θα υπήρχει να φίλτρον εμέσα της επιλογής αυτά είναι από τη
μια μέρια από την άλλη μεριαν όμως υπάρχουν και σε μας κάποια βέβαα είναι εδώ
και εξη χρόνια τογέσή μας και εδωσε μεγάλη προσφορά στην ιγείααναφισβίαητα ότι βρίσκεται τώρα σε
μια κοινούρια φάση που βάζει πιοτικά κριτήρια που κοιτάζει ένα ορθολογήσει ωρισμένες από τις παιδικές
του ασθενείες αναφισβίεται αυτό θα βοηθήσει εναι και αυτός σε μια εξέλεξη χρειάζεται και αυτό
μια κριτική βέβαια καλόπιστη η κριτική να γίνεται πάντα αναγνωρίζοντας την προσφορά